hi i'm christos goodrow i'm johanna
voulich wright we're from the youtube
search and discovery team and this
is the wired
autocomplete interview
what we do is we help our viewers find
the videos that they want to watch
[Music]
how youtube
uses machine learning youtube uses
machine learning in two basic ways the
first way is to keep the site safe so we
use machine learning to comb through the
huge database of videos and find
anything that violates our community
guidelines and if something doesn't pass
our community guidelines based on our
machine learning then we'll send it out
to human evaluators and they will make a
judgment about whether or not that video
should come down and the other way that
we use machine learning is to keep the
site fun there we use it to build out
our recommendation engine so the home
page the watch next search engine
also
we have our own youtube autocomplete
just kind of like this and that is built
by machine learning so the latest
and greatest form of machine learning is
often called deep neural networks it's
basically you're creating a network
that's
a little bit like what you might imagine
your brain and then you're putting a
bunch of information in the network and
then these neurons all pass that
information through to try to get an
answer and the way you train this is by
basically doing that getting an answer
showing this network what the right
answer was and then the network tries to
adjust itself to get closer to the right
answer the next time the first places
that we started using deep neural
networks was in recommendations but now
it's permeated many other parts of the
system how to compress or what's the
best way to stream a video the quality
of the network in that location and
things like that how youtube algorithm
works how many lines of code is the
algorithm oh my gosh i would say it's in
the hundreds of thousands at least how
youtube
search works we actually call this our
search and discovery system this is the
system whereby we show people videos
recommend videos to them our goal is to
make sure that everybody has a video
that they want to watch and we do this
by using over 80 billion signals things
like videos that you've watched before
clicked on liked disliked actually one
of the biggest pieces of the algorithm
is people who watch things like you have
also watched so just this notion of the
wisdom of the crowds is a really big
piece of the algorithm youtube search
tries to find the video that you're
looking for based on the query that
you've entered it does this by using the
query the terms in the query and
matching them to the information we have
about the video in particular the title
the description and even some
information we might have from the video
content itself now
for some kinds of queries for instance
entertainment queries
we're really just trying to find the
video that you're most satisfied with
and that's most relevant to the query
but for certain topics like health and
politics we want to make sure that the
videos that are at the top come from
credible trustworthy sources for news
and for health and for sensitive areas
we always try and raise up authoritative
sources but then in other areas like
entertainment areas we rely on things
like clicks and other things to
determine the relevance and how closely
related the results are to the query the
person has entered how youtube
ranks videos well we use over 80 billion
signals in the case of search results
we're really focused on matching the
video to the query that the user has
entered but
in our home page and our watch next we
use signals like what videos you've
watched before
liked disliked clicked on how you've
responded to surveys about those videos
how youtube recommends videos we use our
website our app and we put videos that
we recommend on the home page and also
right after a video you've watched so we
use those surfaces as a place to
recommend videos to people we try to
make sure that the videos that are
recommended are the ones that you'll
find the most value from particular
we send people surveys after they've
watched videos asking them how did you
enjoy this video and would you rate it
from one to five stars and we try to
make sure that the recommendations we
make in the future are those that will
only get four and five stars out of five
you might ask why does youtube even
recommend videos i think the best way to
think of this is that youtube is like a
modern library a library might have
thousands of books and have librarians
helping you find what to read whereas at
youtube we have billions of videos and
without a recommendation system how
would
you know what video to watch when you
get there so that's why having a
recommendation system is so important
how youtube
views translate to money so for youtube
creators who've joined our partner
program we share revenue from the ads
that are played on the videos where
people watch from your channel when you
watch a video the watch turns into a
view does youtube count your own views
yes youtube does count your views if you
watch your own video youtube will count
those views now of course if you just
try to refresh the browser to get more
views then then youtube won't count
those so if you watch your video a few
times youtube will definitely count them
some people might wonder is there a way
to like hack the views so that i could
just get lots and lots of views on my
own video we just have lots of
mechanisms at youtube to prevent spam
and things like this so yeah you can
watch your video once or twice but you
can't like run a video watching farm of
your own video that's not going to be
allowed you're not going to be able to
raise the views that way does youtube
count views without account yes if
you're logged out and you watch videos
then those views will get counted does
youtube
count loops as views yes i think we do
count loops as views does youtube count
repeat views yes youtube counts repeat
views there's not a particular cutoff
for how long you have to watch it i
think the system that does the counting
of the views
makes a decision about that based on the
setting that you're in so it may be
different if for instance you're
watching a playlist of videos versus if
you're maybe finding a video on some
other website and clicking on it what
youtube
what youtube first video oh
this was me at the zoo by our founders
chad steve and joewood starring jolwood
standing in front of an elephant
at the zoo what's youtube's
most
liked video well the most liked video is
despacito is the most liked video
because despacito is awesome it's also
in a very popular language so people
listen to it in english but it's also
sung in spanish so it's got the
opportunity for a huge global audience
that's right what's youtube's
most viewed video okay yeah this is my
turn to sing
oh no is that baby shark yeah baby shark
is the most viewed video and i think
something like baby shark is something
sometimes people love to hate right you
love to hate baby sharks so that's why i
think it's the most viewed but
potentially not the most liked video and
the first video to get a billion views
was
oppam gangnam style yeah gangnam style
was actually the reigning most viewed
for quite some time and that's
interesting because
again another video that wasn't in
english but appealed worldwide likes are
many fewer than views they tend to be a
slightly stronger indication of
appreciation or value on the part of the
viewer but we found that people will
like videos for a variety of reasons not
just because they really enjoyed it what
youtube
record did bts break i believe that bts
broke the
top
views in 24 hours 108
million views in 24 hours bts butter was
the video current record holder bts
butter so would you say that bts was
doing us a favor by having such an
awesomely popular video bts should
absolutely make more record-breaking
videos that would be fabulous for for
everybody really what youtube
knows about me i don't know what youtube
knows about you christos
that is an interesting question youtube
typically knows the videos that you've
watched the things that you've liked
that you've disliked you have a profile
you can enter things like your age your
name you can put in a profile picture
you can look and see your watch history
and so you'll know what videos you've
watched and liked and it knows what i
subscribe to it knows what i've uploaded
keeps track of that for me too you can
change your settings to have it store
the data forever and that's what i do
because i really like it to remember
which things i like and which things i
didn't like and improve my
recommendations but if i ever decide
that i don't want it to have that data
anymore it's very easy to delete it why
youtube was created youtube was created
to give everyone a voice and show them
the world youtube was created as a way
for people to share videos at a time
when it was becoming possible to create
videos and upload them and share them
via the internet why youtube is called
youtube because you put the you on you
in youtube the user generated content
and because tube is what we used to call
televisions so you put those together
you get youtube why youtube ads are
annoying are they annoying i'm sorry
we're sorry that they're annoying we
endeavor to find ads that are not
annoying i myself have found some really
great ads but if you don't like an ad
then on the mobile app you can actually
dislike it and that will encourage the
system to not show you that kind of ad
again why youtube recommending old
videos we want to make sure that we can
recommend the new videos that are
uploaded as quickly as possible but
there are also old videos that are
fabulous and we want to make sure that
people who enjoy those will get those
recommended as well really sometimes
these old videos can really be a gem
there really are some
esoteric cool videos on youtube and the
system doesn't really expire videos
after a certain amount of time if it's
still available the system's trying to
find an audience for it why youtube
recommends same videos ah we'd rather
not the system recommend the same videos
all the time sometimes this is great
because you're into a particular topic
or you want to see something again often
music videos people like to hear music
videos again and again but in many cases
this is not great one of the issues i've
noticed though is that people might use
different accounts or devices sometimes
they're logged in sometimes they're
logged out if the system can't keep
track of the videos that you've watched
across those accounts or devices then it
really has no way to prevent
recommending the same thing to you
sometimes
videos aren't technically the same but
they might seem the same just think
about like two videos that are
re-uploaded and are kind of similar or
it's just the same creator and they make
things that are kind of alike and so
you're like oh man i've seen so much of
this similar creator that you feel like
it's the same so sometimes we look at
complaints from users saying that
they've been recommended the same video
and it turns out they actually haven't
but it still feels the same so this is
actually just a really it's really
tricky area for us does youtube
channel location matter i think the
biggest thing to think about here more
than like where you posted is something
like language language probably matters
a lot since youtube is a global site
people from all around the world watch
youtube so if you're gonna have a video
in spanish you might have a much
wider audience than say if you were
posting a video in french does youtube
description matter it does matter we see
a lot of our viewers clicking on it to
learn more about the video so making a
good description will matter people will
read it and we use that description in
search along with the title and other
information about the video to match the
query does youtube
favor longer videos this i believe
within the creator community is a hotly
debated topic and our systems don't
inherently like one video
length more than another but
different people do favor different
length videos say christos likes long
videos what we will endeavor to do is to
recommend him longer videos and if i
like shorter videos we will recommend me
shorter videos and so this is really a
personal taste and if youtube favored
longer videos then how could we explain
the popularity of music videos on
youtube which aren't really that long
does youtube
favor new channels we try to make sure
that the site is fresh and relevant and
so that may be from new channels but
also old channels uploading new videos
new old all should have a chance to
succeed and our system really does try
to find an audience for brand new
channels it's challenging
but we have special parts of the system
that are designed to try to help new
channels find an audience i think if
you're a creator you might be thinking
oh should i make a new channel would it
favor that but it's actually hard for
youtube to favor new channels because
once a channel's existed for a while it
develops a lot of history it's developed
an audience youtube will know
which people will want to watch those
videos if you're a new channel none of
those signals none of that information
exists so we want all new channels to
succeed but it's actually hard for us to
favor new channels even if we wanted to
who
trending on youtube i don't know who's
trending on youtube why do we have to
check and find out is it mr beast mr
beast maybe or squid squid game i think
trending tries to find the videos that
are catching on and that usually means
that they're getting a lot of views
relative to what we might otherwise
expect for that creator in a very short
period of time so they're they're kind
of like spiking where
to upload youtube
shorts
you can upload youtube shorts from your
mobile phone if you have the youtube app
on a mobile phone then you just push the
plus button the create button select
create short and you can
add effects and add music and just have
a fun time creating a short and
uploading it can youtube
auto translate it sure can youtube can
absolutely auto translate making that
system better and better all the time
and you can turn on the translated
subtitles right in the youtube player
this is actually one of our most
powerful features especially for people
who speak languages that there has not
been as much content written in so
around the world like in india there's
many languages spoken but maybe there's
not as much content written you can get
content auto-translated from english or
other languages hindi into your language
it's really a big deal more globally
maybe than in the united states can
youtube
find you fine you
i don't think so no youtube cannot find
you youtube
wired autocomplete wait that's us right
what we're doing right now are we
supposed to answer that interestingly
recursive i think the easiest way for
wired to get more views of this video is
to make sure that we look very cool and
are very funny so people want to watch
it